working women will have a kid they'll
prioritize their career this is what
happens in many cases
and who is the one who is forced to pay
the price who for this sacrifice and
time it's the kid it's a kid that
doesn't have the mother for those eight
hours a day when their mom's at work
it's the kid who mom can't go to the
game mom can't pick you up when you're
sick from school mom can't do X Y and Z
nobody can have everything of everything
nobody can have it all we have to make
decisions which means sacrifice and the
problem that is going on if women want
to work their whole life and never have
kids I don't think that's good for them
I don't think that's fulfilling but
worse still is you have women that are
promiscuous which is a mortal sin
they'll wind up having kids often become
a single mom and even if they're not the
kids wind up in daycare and the point is
is it's just a very selfish lifestyle
people should put their family first